okay how long has this alleged blackmail
dossier blackmail file on Donald Trump
existed its existed for a while
we now are learning that the CIA I'm
sorry that the FBI had this dossier as
early as summer of 2016 we thought maybe
I mean you kind of mentioned to me Pat
that you thought maybe this entire thing
was gonna blow over right yeah oh the
dossier we're never gonna hear about the
dossier again quite the opposite is
happening
and you've been surprised by it haven't
you the stories seem to have fizzled out
a bit over the weekend and now we're
learning more and more about how long
these agencies have had this information
for right and that's what's bringing
back the skepticism well the Senate
Intelligence leaders have announced that
they're going to look into not just
allegations of links between Trump and
Russia which is sort of like verifying
the base material but also into the
revelation that FBI director Comey had
the Trump Russia file in summer of 2016
and you'll remember during that time
Comey writing multiple letters holding a
press conference about Hillary Clinton's
email investigation which led to nothing
and yet Comey didn't feel it necessary
to mention that they had an insanely
damning document even recently Comey has
continued to refuse to confirm nor deny
whether the FBI is even looking into the
Russia ties it was so funny he was asked
in a briefing I think it was by Senator
angus King to confirm or deny whether
this is something that they're looking
into and he said you know I don't really
comment in public about whether an
investigation is or isn't going on Oh
Jimmy weren't you the guy who made three
public pronouncements about an
investigation into Hillary Clinton that
was not going anywhere and then was
reopened and then again wasn't going
anywhere
how can he say with a straight face in
public pat that the FBI doesn't comment
about the existence or lack of existence
of investigations when he did it three
times with Hillary Clinton
yeah and Comey spoke with members of the
Senate and then the house the next day
and even though that was behind closed
doors yeah you could tell that when
these politicians got out of those rooms
they were clearly upset with Comey
because there seems to be a double
standard there oh absolutely that's a
double standard and the ironic or tragic
part is
it doesn't it's not clear whether we
should be laughing or crying about this
is that the FBI had the report over the
summer and basically ignored it then
later you'll remember last week I told
you that it came to the attention of
Senator John McCain a Republican no less
who said hey you know what I don't know
if this stuff is true or not I'm going
to give it to the FBI and we now know
that the FBI was already ignorant not
only did they know about it they'd
already chosen to ignore it that it and
of course the birthers by the way are
saying oh these are scummy conspiracy
documents that are untrustworthy they
went on for years
about the layering of President Obama
supposedly fake birth certificate and
reports from WorldNetDaily and Infowars
about it
now they're saying Oh BuzzFeed it's
amazing yeah and that was the prime
example at the time of fake news and
guess who started that controversy
Donald Trump I saw I think it was
written is it Reince or rinsed right I
like to say rinse it just seems oh yeah
rinse Priebus said the other day that
nobody in the Republican Party was
doubting President Obama's citizenship
or something like that like were you I
mean the guys in his 40s I think it's
not like he was a two-year-old five
years ago when the entire birther thing
was going on they'll say anything and
the trumpets will eat it right up if you
were looking to hire somebody you need
to know where to post the job in order
to get the best candidates and today's
sponsor zip recruiter allows you to post
your job in one place but have it listed
all over all of the most important job
sites and social media sites as well and
one of the great things about zip
recruiter is that they have a sort of
hiring dashboard which allows you to not
only add other team members if this is a
group higher or if multiple people are
involved in the hiring process it also
allows you to rank rate and leave notes
about candidates as well as track where
you are with each candidate in the
hiring process this is all part of the
zip recruiter system you don't have to
juggle emails or create a spreadsheet or
deal with various calls to your office
or between team members you screen the
candidates you rate them and
you hire the right person fast which is
really the most important thing and if
you have any issues zip recruiter has an
actual team of real people that can help
you out you can find out today why zip
recruiter has been used by over a
million businesses and right now my
listeners can post jobs on zip recruiter
for free by going to zip recruiter
dot-com slash free trial
that's zip recruiter com forward slash
free trial one more time try it free zip
recruiter dot-com slash free trial